أعني أن كاحليك لم يكن تقريبًا وحشيًا
كما تعرف أنت تقول أن العديد من النساء قد عانين من
ما كان عليه الأمر بالنسبة لك
المهين
الذي تم استقبالي فيه لأنني كان لدي
جزء من كاحلي يظهر تحت
تنورتي الطويلة.
لم أرتدي الجوارب مع حذاء التنس الخاص بي
وكنت محاطًا بمجموعة من
الأخوات ، كان الأمر مثل الفصيل النسائي
في شرطة الأخلاق وتعرضت للتوبيخ
ثم تم نقلي إلى المحطة
حيث كنت في غرفة بمفردي مع
قام شرطي بتوبيخني
بتوبيخي ، وفي تلك اللحظة علمت أنني شعرت
بالرعب لأنني كنت أعرف المظهر
الخاطئ أو الكلمة الخاطئة أو تعبير الوجه الخاطئ
أو الاتصال المباشر بالعين ، من شأنه أن يؤدي إلى
تصعيد الموقف إلى شيء
يشبه الكابوس.
كانت في كل مرة أشارك فيها مع
شرطة الأخلاق أو كان CG السيئ
أكثر تجربة مرعبة في حياتي